[Music]  please welcome our own audience ease  fashion assassin James st. Claire st.  Wallens okay okay let's see my first  fashion victim oh this is torture  I feel like you just waterboarded my  eyeball look even your hair shocked you  wore that outfit today I bet you thought  we were done with you that  black-on-black outfit is abracadabra  here's the question if you're here who's  making popcorn at the local art house  movie theater come on Queen Daniel let's  go get Froyo with dina Lohan  [Applause]  [Music]  I hate that guy in fact everybody hates  James Sinclair Satan well and so here's  some revenge I found a hidden camera  footage of him bathing in a Burger King  restroom occupied  [Music]  [Applause]  that was our audience e Awards for the  night and as always this show was a big  hit  [Applause]